what is protectionism
protectionists want to shield their own
country from foreign competition so they
establish barriers the domestic economy
receives preferential treatment it's
being protected protectionists often
subsidize domestic industries in the EU
for example that could be meat or
electric vehicles tariffs are imposed on
products manufactured in foreign
countries to curtail imports that makes
foreign products televisions for example
more expensive and therefore less
attractive to consumers at first it may
seem to work domestic manufacturing gets
a boost more workers are hired and
foreign competitors that produce more
cheaply are edged out by by free trade
but the products produced at home are
more expensive and not always
state-of-the-art since there's no
competition from abroad innovation
begins to lag growth also starts to
stagnate companies produce almost
exclusively for the domestic market
neighboring countries respond by
instituting protectionist measures of
their own and introduced import tariffs
this is what happened after the 1929
stock market crash in the u.s. within
just a few years global trade declined
by two-thirds once one country
Institute's protectionist measures
others follow in a kind of domino effect
over time protectionists countries tend
to develop self-sufficient economies
whether it's carrots apples or bananas
whatever doesn't grow at home is no
longer sold goods become more scarce and
growth suffers and what about the
protectionists they're left with a
mountain of debt subsidies are expensive
history has shown that a wave of
protectionism is often followed by a
financial crisis and even government
default that's usually followed by
renewed support for free trade